hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the topics
that keeps coming up over and over again
in st. Augustine's free choice of the
will are the virtues and to a lesser
extent the vices you know by contrast if
you're going to talk about virtues you
really necessarily end up talking about
their opposites the vices and Augustine
is not trying to give us an entire
theory of the virtues in this work it's
kind of a tangential topic that he keeps
coming back to it is important it does
help you understand what he's talking
about particularly in terms of the will
and how the will Orient's itself as
we'll see in just a moment
one thing that's really important to
point out is he is not talking about all
of the virtues and he's putting it in a
somewhat theological framework but he's
not talking about what we call the
theological virtues so Faith Hope
charity you know if we have the sort of
traditional seven virtues
Canha schema instead he's talking about
these cardinal virtues that we first see
talked about in an organized systematic
way by Plato in the Republic and then
sort of you know reconsidered by
Aristotle Aristotle you know doesn't
have a schema of the Cardinal
usually that play-doh did and these
three right here end up being moral
virtues this this one prudence or wisdom
ends up being an intellectual virtue is
closely tied with moral virtue then the
Stoics take this up and other people by
the time that Augustine is writing about
this this is a pretty well-established
schema of the virtues and what are the
virtues well they are their traits that
represent perfections of character
ideals you might say things that we can
strive for ways in which a human being
is good not only good for other people
but but good for themselves and good in
their relationship with other people and
if you put in a theological framework in
relation to God as well so these are the
cardinal virtues that he's going to talk
about and what we're going to talk about
here we're gonna look at here is what
Augustine has to say about you know the
specifics of these virtues and where
they actually are what they actually are
his view on them was a little bit
different than a lot of other people
that we might might associate with him
and then we're gonna look at how the
virtues are connected with the will and
with reason and we're gonna you know
sort of approach this in all all these
different topics tied in together I'm
gonna jump around a little bit in the
the the work itself some of the stuff is
in book one and then he lets it lay for
a while and he takes it up again in book
two and then you know book three so
we're gonna we're gonna jump around a
little bit but but not all that much so
let's start with thinking about these
virtues in general so Augustine in book
one the the central question there is
you know who's responsible for bad
things for for evil bad actions in
particular and as the answer as well as
human beings God you know didn't make
them do anything evil it's they they
choose willingly to do the wrong things
you know it's not in a vacuum it's not
as if they just were going to walk along
and say I think I'd like to do something
awful instead they allow their their
passions their desires to call the shots
we might say and the will is sort of
wavers in between reason and for
Augustine reason generally doesn't go
bad right or the passions and desires
and even the passions and desires in
themselves are not something bad but
they can lead us to do inordinate things
they can lead us to value the wrong
things too highly and the right things
too lowly so the will is generally
better enough you know listening to
reuse and then of the passions and
desires but the will gets to choose
between these so where do the virtues
come in with us well the virtues are
particularly in which our will gets
formed there you might say patterns
after which the will can get formed
model itself take on it you know
determinate shapes over time and they're
they're tied in with knowledge they're
tied in with understanding with wisdom
with reason they're also tied in with
the structure of the will and in some
cases what the will has to do in
relation to passions or desires so let's
see what Augustine actually has to tell
us about about these there's a passage
in book 1 where he and his student of
odious are going back and forth and he
asks Laveau dias consider whether
prudence seems to you to consist in the
knowledge of what to seek and what to
avoid so that's that's a pretty standard
definition of prudence a form of
knowledge not in the sense of
information that's you know I'm some
sort of book where you can just read it
off of a list oh here's what I ought to
do here's what I have a void but
embodied habitually developed knowledge
that you've actually made your own which
you can also apply to your own case and
to those of others so he said the 40
says yeah I think that that's that's the
case I think it is knowledge of what to
seek and what to avoid fortitude is not
fortitude
courage that state of the soul in which
we despise all misfortunes and the loss
of things not resting in our power so
this is also a kind of knowledge this is
a fairly platonic
although Aristotle also thinks that
courage does seem to involve some sort
of knowledge of what what law to be
feared and what not to be feared what a
lot to be despised instead
so why Argos Tina puts it in terms of
loss of things not residing in our power
which is in some ways closer to the the
the Stoics who who you know explicitly
focused on that sort of thing in this
case of course it's going to be tied in
with his conception of you know God
eternal goods the eternal law the
virtues having a good will all those
sorts of things so fortitude is a virtue
that lets us resist getting tied in with
things that really are not you know in
our power to to maintain to control it
keeps us from valuing to highly
uncertain goods temperance temperance he
says do you agree that temperance is
that state of soul which controls and
checks desire in regard to those things
which it is shameful to desire so notice
it's it's not that temperance controls
all desire whatsoever
you know Augustine is is not a prude
he's a guy who actually understands sins
of the flesh quite well he actually at
one point says you know Lord give me
give me you know continents but not yet
help me out you know with these these
sins of the flesh that is pursuing
things that are you know we have
inordinate desires for in inordinate
ways but not quite yet so Augustine
really understood this stuff well he is
not saying temperance --is is sort of
like turning off the body altogether
instead it's it's a virtue because it it
applies to the right things it applies
to for example I mean you shouldn't be
going around having sex with anybody who
presents themselves that's going to get
you in trouble you shouldn't go around
eating everything or even tasting
everything
you shouldn't be drinking all the time
or you know there's there's some things
I suppose that you probably shouldn't
even do once you know so Augustine is
saying temperance is in fact this is
virtue that helps us to control and
check desire in regard to these things
which is shameful to desire and then
injustice what is justice
it's the virtue by which each man is
given his due each person is given what
they deserve
again fairly typical understandings of
these virtues Augustine is not breaking
a lot of new ground with these now
Augustine is asking about the person who
has the goodwill and he says the man who
has a goodwill will love this alone his
most precious possession will delight in
this and make it as joy and pleasure
there's a reflexivity and I talked about
this in some of the other videos the
course videos that I've done to the will
where the goodwill is itself something
good it has to be valued above just the
satisfaction of the desires the goodwill
is going to be a will that's in line
with reason but the goodwill is
something that the in reason can tell
the goodwill hey you ought to hold on to
yourself you want value yourself this
way but only the will can actually make
that choice can actually sort things out
in that way practically in the way one's
life is lived so how do the virtues
figure into this that's where it gets
particularly interesting he says the man
who has a goodwill will love this alone
will delight in this make it Joanna's
pleasure realizing fully its value and
then he cannot be robbed of it against
this against his will the only way in
which you can lose the goodwill is by
choosing the value of something else
higher you know some say honor or wealth
or sexual satisfaction or revenge or
whatever so he says surely we cannot
doubt that he will be opposed to all
that conflicts with this one good and he
says yeah he's going to be opposed to it
so how do the virtues come in can we
suppose such a man is not endowed with
prudence prudence is
what in fact allows us to see that the
good will in determinate circumstances
when we're actually being tempted when
we're inclined to make a you know not an
example when we're inclined to make an
exception for ourselves and say well you
know usually it's wrong to seek revenge
what I'm gonna do in this case and it's
okay for me in this case well you know
that means giving up the good will and
prudence would would counsel against
that so prudence
he says sees that this good should be
sought for and everything avoided which
conflicts with them
prudence helps us to hold on to the good
will by knowing indeterminate
circumstances where the rubber meets the
road so to speak what we ought to do and
what choices we ought to make even if we
don't really feel like making them so he
says what about fortitude why should we
not great in fortitude he cannot love
and value highly all these all these
things not under our control you know
honor well even to a certain extent
relationships insofar as we turn them
into a kind of idol and say that you
know we have to have those certain way
of viewing ourselves can be considered
with that satisfaction of our bodily
desires the desire to dominate other
people all these sorts of things are not
actually under our control and they're
not goods that we can not be deprived of
against her will so we ought to we ought
to rank those kind of wool and he says
they're loved through an evil will and
he's bound to resist an evil will is the
enemy of his most precious good if
you've got a good will and part of that
good will means you want to hold on to
that good will when it comes down to
choosing some lesser good and choosing
to maintain your good will then
fortitude is part of what helps you
despise those other those other goods
that doesn't mean saying that they're
not good it just means putting them in
the proper perspective
so what about temperance
well temperance checks passion he says
what is so opposed to a good will is
passion so the man who loves is goodwill
does this is passion by every means and
fights against them as a matter of fact
if you're smart about this sort of thing
and Augustine again is very smart about
these sort of things you'll realize that
you're almost never going to be totally
free of passions that want you to do
more for them to satisfy them then then
you want to then his ordinate then is
then as you know within proper bounds
and so you actually need temperance to
help you out to like you know sort these
these matters through when you're in in
moments of temptation
so temperance is needed and then finally
justice says there remains justice I
certainly do not see how such a man can
lack this if he possesses and loves to
possess a good will and resisted my sin
what is opposed to it he cannot wish
evil to anyone
it follows he harms no one and this
could only be the case if he gives to
everyone his due so we start you know
with this notion of justice as giving
everybody their due and Augustine is
interpreting this in a somewhat more
expanded way so that the person who's
just is not actually going to harm
anyone you might say well what about
punishment or you know fighting under
orders or stuff like that you know
Augustine would say harm is being done
in one sense but also not being done in
another sense you know punishment is
actually to to improve the person who's
being punished and you don't nobody
likes it but that's that's the way that
it works coming back to this with
justice so if you actually have a good
will a will that not only is directed
the right way but wants to be directed
the right way and sees that as a good
then that is going to entail having
justice justice is going to consolidate
the goodwill in relation to two other
people so you know like the temperance
it's in relation to the path
that you feel for other things justice
it's going to be in relation to other
people and your relationships with them
and your dealings with them and even
perhaps you know if you're a judge there
are relationships with each other or
their dealings with each other or this
kind of society that you live in so like
he says you remember I think you agreed
when I said this was the concern of
Justice giving everyone their due of
odious says yes I accepted your account
of the four virtues just now and agree
that all of them are present in the man
who values high Liam loves his goodwill
so this is really a central concept for
Augustine the goodwill the person who
really exemplifies this and you know
keep in mind he's talking about sort of
an ideal here he's not talking about
every single person who's sort of on
their way towards this ideal the person
who he has this ideal of you know the
completely goodwill is going to have all
of these virtues fully developed and and
you know you might say well which came
first the virtues are the goodwill kind
of go together there's a dialectical
relationship between them if you
actually have that that goodwill then
you're going to want to cultivate these
virtues and while you're cultivating
these virtues these are ways of taking
your will which is not completely good
at one point and trying to sort of fix
it up in process so that's something
from from book one now I'm going to go
on to book two in book two Augustine
tells us a little bit more about where
these virtues they actually come from
and a lot of people look at virtues as
character traits right an Augustine
thinks that their character traits so
they tend to think of them as having
their existence in the person themselves
and Augustine would say yeah that depth
that's true and where specifically well
in part
ocular in the the will right so these
cardinal virtues are things that are
shaping the will and its battle with
passion or desire its attempt to follow
reason but that's not the whole story
where are these virtues they actually
coming from so Augustine says this in
book two
he says he's talking about about how we
gain knowledge about things he says it's
enough that you see as I do and admit to
be quite certain that those principles
and illuminations so to speak in which
the virtues appear so principles and
illuminations the illumination means you
too shedding light
gaining insight the virtues are not
things that are just in us they're ways
in which we actually participate in
something greater than us so you know
what do we have over here eternal goods
you know God eternal law truth wisdom
and the virtues the virtues here honesty
niskanen platonic the virtues are not
something that just exists in us there
are the virtues out there most developed
wherever they exist in God right and in
a certain way by participating in these
virtues we participate in the divine
economy however you want to frame it
right the mind of God Providence all
these these sorts of things so when we
actually have a virtue in ourselves that
virtue is being patterned after
something which is virtue per se right
so we call these principles and
illumination so to speak in which the
virtues appear these are true and
unchangeable so what about the virtues
in us you know if we're building these
through pruning our will through using
the will to modify itself through say
listening to good guidance adapting
so stupid models resisting temptations
picking ourselves up and you know making
things right after we screw up and give
in to these temptations you know for
temporal Goods / eternal Goods we're in
process of change so the virtues in us
are not unchanging and eternal but they
are over here they are in God or in the
mind of God or in the illuminations that
were were being given so he says whether
separately or all together these are
present in common to the sight of those
who can see them each with his own
reason in mind so reason is part of what
you know gets illuminated and grasps
these virtues it's the will that he has
to endorse them it's the will that has
to take them on and say yes I want these
so he's easy asking about these and he
puts this in terms of wisdom I think a
little bit later he says so it's quite
clear that those principles and
illuminations as we've called them in
which the virtues appear concern wisdom
the more man uses them in living his
life and the more he passes his life and
conformity to them the more wisely
healeth he lives and acts but nothing
which is done wisely can rightly be
called distinct from wisdom so there is
wisdom in in sort of an eternal sense
and then there's wisdom as we
participate in it which is something
that can grow in us something that can
you know wane in us if we don't if we
don't practice it we don't align
ourselves properly with with the greater
things that that transcend us so the
virtues insofar like he says insofar the
more than a man uses them in living his
life so you you practice the virtues
through the way that you actually live
the way that you choose the way that you
eat drink celebrate the ways that you
mourn the ways that you console other
people the ways that you deal with other
people day to day whether you're a jerk
whether you are a good person you know
whether you're generous and kind whether
you're cruel whether you forgive whether
you
hold grudges all these sorts of things
that the very fabric of our ordinary
life is a locus in which the virtues can
be developed according to these
illuminations that are provided to
anybody who wants to have them he says
now the more that a person passes his
life and conformity with them the more
wisdom they acquire so wisdom for for
Augustine is not just a matter of sort
of intellectual as opposed to practical
knowledge and it's not even going to be
something that is devoid of emotion so
let's go on from from there we've
already made quite a bit of progress and
thinking about this we come back to
thinking about these these virtues again
again this is in book two and he says
it's free we'll look good that's one of
the preoccupations of book 2 so he says
let's let's you know make a contrast
here let's think about these virtues so
let's take justice take justice which no
one uses wrongly if you actually have
justice you're not going to screw things
up that's what it means to actually
fully possess a virtue so this is
counted among the highest goods proper
to man and among all the souls virtues
which go up to make a right and worthy
life no one uses wrongly either prudence
or attempt or fortitude or temperance so
all these cardinal virtues we can't go
wrong with them according to Augustine
other moral theorists later on like you
know contour Bentham will say you know
courage for example can be used for all
sorts of terrible things Augustine is
much more you know platonic in the sense
if you actually have courage courage
includes knowledge of what you ought to
despise and what you you know what you
ought to take seriously what you ought
to resist and you're not going to go
wrong with it so he says in all of these
right reason reigns without without
which no virtues can exist no one can
use right great reason wrongly so the
virtues are a kind of good
that can't be used wrongly they are good
in themselves and they're just good he
says the powers of the soul so here
we're looking at this time without which
we cannot live right we are the middle
Goods no one uses the virtues wrongly
but anyone can use the other Goods the
middle and the least wrongly as well as
rightly no one uses virtue wrongly
because and here's a sort of a
definition that Thomas Aquinas will take
up the work of virtue is the good use of
those things which we are capable of
using wrongly so you know the work of
virtue
is to help us to make good use of things
all these kinds of goods which we can go
wrong with with these temporal Goods we
can go wrong and how we use them we can
go wrong and how we order them in
relation to each other or to the eternal
Goods we're not actually going to go
wrong in respect to the eternal Goods
except insofar as we you know may be
subordinate them to the temporal Goods
the virtues help us to keep from doing
that they help us to make the right
orderings when we get into the
nitty-gritty of of actual decisions so
he says what about freewill freewill
that's something that we can use wrongly
as a matter of fact we know that we
visit wrongly an awful lot right it says
if we use other things by means of
freewill we can also use freewill itself
by means of itself so we can actually
the the will is reflexive so they says
when the will which is a middle good
clings to the unchangeable good not as a
private possession not selfishly not
saying hey this is mine but it's coming
to all of the same way as the truth then
man possesses the happy life so truth
wisdom the life of the virtues they're
all going to be connected with each
other and he goes on he talks a little
bit more about the virtues he says
nobody is is prude
through another's prudence nobodies
braved through another's bravery
nobody's tempered through another's
temperate nor does a man made just
through another's justice but he becomes
such by conforming his soul to the
unchangeable principles and
illuminations of the virtues which have
incorruptible life and truth itself and
wisdom which is common to all so when
I'm for example learning how to be a
more temperate person by observing
another person who actually is temperate
and saying man that person's got their
life together and I have it be like that
you know instead of being uncontrolled
you know our self-indulgence in this
respect I had a you know do what they do
and then maybe I talk with them and I
say hey you know do you think he could
help me out I'm having trouble with you
know managing my desires with respect to
X Y Z and they say yeah here's what
worked for me I suggested you this maybe
they even say you know st. Augustine
says or Aristotle says or whoever you
know pick whatever instructor you like
what's really going on is there's some
appeal some some directedness that's
going on towards the these eternal
truths that the virtues are part of
virtue is not just the virtues in us or
in another person but the virtues as
archetypical forms as you know that
which is in certain ways more knowable
so he goes on and he says you know the
model this man has set up for himself is
endowed with these virtues and he has
conformed and attached to Saul to these
these virtues now you know there's a lot
more to be said about this but I'm
trying to keep this fairly short so I'm
going to try to move through this are we
so to speak either virtuous or totally
virtuous or totally vicious Augustine
says no he actually says at one point we
need not fear there may be a life half
between the virtue and vice which you
know might you know make us a little bit
nervous and we say oh man I'm not
virtuous I must be vicious and there are
some some places where Augustine talks
as if you know if you don't have the
virtue of justice you're unjust if you
don't have the virtue of temperance
you're intemperate you're through their
one or the other there's no like middle
ground where you're kind of like I'm
working on becoming temperate but I'm
not yet tough I'm not yet temperate and
I'm attracted to in temperance or
anything like that
in this work he actually does address
that and he says there are cases where
we're sort of in between
he says human nature receives a middle
state which cannot rightly be called
either folly or wisdom and folly and
wisdom your foolishness wisdom that has
to do with how we're actually directing
ourself you know all the virtues
themselves are tied in with with wisdom
so like you said folly is not any kind
of ignorance of what we should seek and
what we should avoid but it's vicious
ignorance it's it's being screwed up
it's going such as being ignorant as
such it's like ignorance that you are
responsible for ignorant squared
ignorance that perpetuates itself that
resists its own amending you might say
and now how can this be possible
well Augustine says to be rational as
different than being wise we're all
rational right we all have a Faculty of
reason and that Faculty of Reason can
kind of you know reach out not only into
the world but into within ourselves even
into you know the divine economy into
God and look for things and realize
things that's the only reason works for
Augustine that doesn't mean that we use
it all the time so he says by reason
every man is is made able as a keyword
Abel doesn't mean that it actually
happens it made able to recognize the
command to which you ought to be
faithful and so to carry out what is
commanded as reason of its very nature
makes us recognize the command so
observance of the command makes us gain
wisdom it's not enough just to exercise
reason and
get the information that we need we
actually have to choose it and by
choosing it then we actually start to
acquire wisdom as a kind of fruit that
can take take hold in us put its roots
into our being so he says what nature
does and making us recognize this
command this the will does in making us
observe it as the rational nature is in
a sense the merit of receiving the
command so the observance of the command
is the merit of receiving wisdom so
that's about what goes right what about
what goes wrong he says the evil of sin
so what is sin you know it's it's going
against these these sort of rules that
were getting and we could figure out if
we pay close attention or you know
consult other people who are smarter
than us what we ought to do it consists
in either in neglect either to grasp the
command or to observe it or to practice
the contemplation of wisdom so something
can go wrong with reason something going
wrong with will and then it can take
root inside of us so he says it's clear
there's a state between these two by
which a man passes from wisdom to folly
somebody can be wise and then then they
can screw it up just because you have
wisdom once doesn't mean that you're
actually going to hold on to it you have
to choose it you have to keep valuing it
as a good over these other temporal
Goods an act done in the state cannot be
called an act either folly or wisdom
says in the present life man can only
understand this through what contradicts
it for no mortal man becomes wise unless
he passes from folly foolishness to
wisdom if he makes the pass that
foolishly I mean there's there's there's
stupid understandings of what wisdom
consistent and then if you have one of
those you're not going to become wise it
would be absurd to call it a good action
well if he makes it wisely it's also
absurd to say he already possessed
wisdom before he passed away stuff hence
we see there is a state between the two
which can be described
neither way so it's it's you know it's
it's interesting to see what he's saying
here it's murky the life that we live in
is kind of hard to to to articulate well
exactly where we are you know on our way
to do we have these virtues are we
developing them do we at least recognize
that these are a good thing do we
recognize that we need to grow in our
understanding of what those are which
would be wisdom which would be you know
participating in this this truth here
you know do we need to use our will on
our will more to increase these virtues
in our self are we deficient highly
deficient with respect to them you know
those are all good questions and those
are all things you have to sort of work
out the way he also talks about
corruption and vice and I'm going to
actually go through this fairly quickly
the virtues are goods they are goods
that help us make use right use of other
goods they're goods that are to be
valued for their own sake and their
goods and have to deal with the the
goods that the human being possesses in
being a human being
goods can become corrupted turn to wrong
uses when that happens a kind of
privation is is set up and Augustine
makes use of an example which which a
lot of other thinkers with you know this
one goes back all the way to Aristotle
you don't see that as stone is blind and
that that blindness is actually
something wrong with the stone in a
human being who ought to have sight
blindness is a privation of what ought
to be there it's a lack it's a something
negative
it's different than simply not having
something that you didn't have to have
when it comes to rightly you know use of
right use of reason even the passions
and desires they're right ordering and
especially the right ordering of the
will there's a way or ways in which we
ought to be
insofar as we aren't measuring up to
that we have a lack within ourselves you
know a lot of people talking about this
in terms of brokenness or being damaged
or things like that
I think that makes good sense from an
Augustinian perspective but it's also
ontological there is a corruption a lack
within us and so he talks about this as
vice a vise is actually a corruption of
the the human being says vice is only
evil because it's opposed to the nature
of the thing which has the Vice so you
know when we are not prudent when we're
when we're stupid
pigheaded when we refuse to look at
what's actually good for us when we tell
ourselves lies about what what is
actually to our advantage or a benefit
we're damaging our being we're not only
not deviating from from this we're
damaging ourselves inside in our will
and that's not something that you can
you know get rid of immediately it takes
it takes root it becomes a habit it
becomes what you know what we call a
vice right fortitude
if you can't resist that he's not he's
not thinking so much about battlefield
courage or something like that if you
are so afraid of what people think of
you that you start making all sorts of
stupid decisions that you know are the
wrong thing to do or if you want money
so badly that you'll sell anybody out to
get it that's a lack of fortitude not
just a lack of prudence that's a lack of
fortitude on your part
Augustine would say and what what is the
effect of this well like he says a man
who knows what do you ought to do this
is in book three and does not do it
loses the knowledge of what is right and
the man who has refused to act correctly
when he could loses the power when he
wishes to have it these things have
effects on us that's why when we
actually have some modicum of these
virtues we got to stick with them and
keep on building the the little reserve
that we have because again
if we don't use it we lose it and if we
lose it we cut ourselves off from this
stuff over here
which we need so I'm actually going to
end with with talking about this great
passage in book 1 that I love in part
because it reflects another passage in
the answer he says surely that
punishment should not be thought a light
one which consists in the mind being
ruled by a passion being robbed of its
store of virtue being dragged his
another poor and needy now judging false
for true now defending now attacking
what before it approved and in spite of
this running off into fresh falsehood
now withholding its ascent and most
frightened of often framed of clear
reasoning now despairing of finding any
truth at all and clinging closely to the
darkness of its valley now striving for
the light of understanding and again
falling back through exhaustion
meanwhile the passions rage like tyrants
and throw into confusion the whole soul
and life of men with storms from every
quarter fear on one side desire on
another on another exam or false empty
joy here pain for the thing which was
loved and lost their eagerness to win
what does not possess their grief for an
injury received here burning desire to
avenge it wherever he turns avarice can
confine it self-indulgence dissipate him
ambition master him pride puffed him up
envy torture him sloth drug him
obstinacy roused him oppression afflict
him and countless other feelings which
crowd and exploit the power of passion
can we think there's no punishment at
all which as you see all who do not
cling to wisdom much Inessa must
necessarily suffer what Augustine is
saying is if we don't cultivate these
virtues or aren't we even like you know
misunderstand the nature of these
virtues and we think that there's
something that we can like possesses our
own individual possession forevermore
and we don't align ourselves with you
know the eternal truth is that the
virtues are bound up with if we don't
subject ourselves to that put very short
and in very short terms we're screwed
our intellect is damaged unable to
accomplish what it ought to do the
passions go
control the will even when it wants to
do the right thing finds itself unable
to carry it through doesn't mean that
you you you know you become a terrible
person or something like that bad people
a lot of the time you have a lot of
goodness in them it's just that the bad
stuff ends up overshadowing that because
it ends up turning everything and
twisting everything and like he says you
know if you don't choose the virtues
pretty soon you're choosing the vices
and they will take hold whether you like
it or not and then once they've got a
hold of you they run you until you use
your will hopefully aided by something
else to start building things back up
again
it's almost like you know Augustine is
talking about 12 steps
you know several you know
well thousand in several hundred years
before anybody ever came up with it
he was discussing the same sort of thing
so hopefully and that helped you
understand what the the virtues are
what's going on with all this virtue and
vice talk in on free choice of the will
I guess that's not an entire theory of
it it's more sort of vignettes of what
Augustine will develop more more clearly
and more articulately in other other
works